I need to talk to you about the
implications not for intervention as
such but for thinking about what we all
are doing as we change after eight to
twelve hours on the screen you and I
know you at least are at least similar
to me in that you are on the screen
reading and the characteristics of the
screen are different now
one of the first questions is you know
now we have a very plastic circuit that
reflects what's asked of it what are the
implications inside a mil year that
emphasizes speed immediacy multitasking
continuous partial attention so the
question becomes whether the affordances
of reading on screen will lead us to a
new very different reading brain one in
which text length text complexity
density of thought density of syntax and
the readers memory and attention are
changing or challenging here is a piece
of the cognitive evidence if you will
and part of my work is to really try to
understand what those changes are from
every standpoint from the stamp was just
a reading behavior fix yourself skimming
is the new way to read we zigzag you
weren't spot you browsed you grace
you are not reading in the same linear
ways that we have done before average
attention span looks about half of what
it was with implications for memory so
studies on memory and that's what of
course you could solid eight when you
allocate time to it memory seems to be
diminishing by about half as well now
what are some of the sources of that do
you know how many times our youth
between
let's just say 20 are distracted in a
given hour 27 27 times and I'm not
looking at anybody in particular this is
not a damnation this is just effect most
of our children and youth are basically
using multiple digital devices and they
are multitasking that's a whole set of
questions I'm happy to answer I'm not
going to talk about that right now whole
lot of interesting mixed research on
multitasking but by and large they're
moving like moving like this way now
it's one thing for us who have formed
reading brains it is another thing for
our young who are distracted what are
the implications for them and I will
certainly say this is not just for them
the decrease focus attention is in us as
well and that's a very big story that
some of you might want to probe with me
afterwards but some of the interesting
things that in fact last week I did one
program on NPR in which the the nurse
was saying my reading has changed my
experience of reading has change my
ability to immerse myself in reading is
changed what are the factors and there
are many that go into those changes
[Music]